all right man bullet calf show special
guest in here yeah jag
aka
ryan earl yeah
yeah we're here that's the first time we
announcing that you know i mean my [ __ ]
can't get the exclusive so moving in to
the new year
government name yeah that so so jag will
not i mean obviously your music will
still be up under jag or will you are
you moving everything over to ryan earl
no the music is still the old music will
still be under jag but the new music
definitely gonna be under ryan earl i
like that whole new thing ryan earl in
2022 man
all right well listen you came here
because this is what you do yeah
i feel like what the last time you came
uh at the station with me and head did
you have a dog with you i had a dog with
me that's right i did have a dog with a
puppy with your hands yeah
are we good to go cook
yo let's get to it man we got ryan earl
in here aka jag man and
he one of the coldest in the city one of
the coolest in the world let's get to it
he ain't telling no lies y'all mean
since we normalizing everything this
year this is the year we should
normalize sounding this good
yeah i mean we should normalize bringing
bars back we should normalize these
[ __ ] stop [ __ ] with trash ass rap
[ __ ]
hello
2021
my year 2022
ryan earl you know what it is
yeah
uh [ __ ] be goofy yo nine soldiers
salute me though this a rabb kufi though
got us flow as a stupid old got a
problem the thule blow devil never could
fool me though y'all tripping she could
get wild here [ __ ] coolio we never had
the cameras in cellis this [ __ ] a movie
don't know she love me this lady just
put the drugs in her booty hole that's
facts [ __ ] gotta keep it strapped cause
all these [ __ ] running packs and now
these girls is getting snatched and now
these [ __ ] getting clapped and now you
gotta watch your packs and now you gotta
watch your racks and have somebody watch
your back and you still gotta watch your
back and how these [ __ ] out here
acting like they love you and this act
and i put the underground up on my back
like it's a mad big bruising anybody
wanna fight then it's a match i have a
little [ __ ] looking to the light like
it's a gnat these [ __ ] got the
audacity trying to talk about cassidy
whole time them league owners is
treating boy like your majesty it's kind
of sad to me and [ __ ] i grew up with
is passing me flo petro guess i'm making
up for [ __ ] that's gassing me on this
bomb him and meanwhile the homie was a
baller now he ain't courtney pointing at
me like he's sean kim everybody's
snitching up seem like it's the claim to
fame rest in peace to anybody way too
many names to name they ain't mean to
water [ __ ] down when they told us change
the game no matter what the problem was
my [ __ ] never named the name free my
[ __ ] poo man he was doing [ __ ] divo
foul free my [ __ ] boogie tilly gone
that [ __ ] see little wow son and
anything i [ __ ] touch like i don't
need no child i should probably drop in
20 years and doing greedo style ain't no
[ __ ] ever build no [ __ ] how the hell
you saying that boy steal your [ __ ] and
you know he killed your [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's that weak ass fake friend show up
to the repass and the ski mask [ __ ] who
gonna let the heat blast now everybody
kill us and i'll buy it on my cheap ass
and my baby is a rider i let her ride it
with her freak ass like how these [ __ ]
talking about the crown these [ __ ]
miss me when i be standing near a
nigga's face like [ __ ] hits me they
acting like they with me but when i'm
gone these [ __ ] diss me you can't get
me with that [ __ ] you gotta miss me
with that [ __ ] it's shag
you know what it is [ __ ] ryan earl ryan
earl aka jack that's that's how we're
doing it big big 22 big big 20 22 coming
for you yeah big 20 22. let's go yeah
hello